what if you jumped into a pool full of  stomach acid  as soon as you take the plunge you'll  feel stinging in your eyes and your  nostrils stomach acid is compared to  battery acid in terms of the damage it  can do if you didn't get out right away  the acid would slowly eat your skin  this would eventually leave you covered  in second and third degree burns  if you didn't manage to cover your eyes  during the swim you'd slowly lose your  vision and end up blind  and your nose it would dissolve from the  inside if the acid touched it long  enough  oh and if you accidentally swallow some  of it you'll inevitably vomit it back up  you'd be best to leave stomach acid  where it belongs and that's inside of us  digesting our food  so have you ever asked yourself